Speaker 1: Let's go to our old
friend Brody from Dallas. Brody,
please don't torpedo today's session of calls.
Speaker 6: I'm going to do my best. David,
how's it going, man? Going well. Awesome. Hey,
so we're fighting the good fight out here in
Texas. We recently had a huge fiasco in the
primary elections. We had a huge disparity.
We had about eight hundred and fifty Democratic
primary voters had their mail in ballots rejected
and less than 10 Republican primary voters had
their ballots rejected. One of the things we've
struggled with here is getting help from D.C.
I know that there is talk about Joe mention,
possibly carving out some things for different
voting rights legislation. What I wanted to know
is what do you see as the most viable path for
states like Texas to have protection from D.C.?
Or do you believe that it's just going to have
to come from all the state legislatures? And as
a follow up, what would you like to see happen?
Speaker 1: So the I don't I don't know exactly
what you're referring to in Texas. So without
knowing the dynamics of it, it's very hard to say
specifically what could address that? So
just with that, as a kind of disclaimer,
I would love to see a new Voting Rights Act that
restricts the things that states can do and allows
for federal oversight. I think many states,
you know, they with a couple of years ago,
states were sort of released from their
requirements to pre-clear changes.
I think we need to be adding more requirements
in terms of changes that states want to make.
That would be the ideal thing. I don't know that
that's going to happen. And so of course, it would
be great if states did legislation on voting
rights within their own states. But the problem
is, Republican controlled states don't really have
any interest in doing that. So it's a very tough
situation. I don't know what the answer is.
Speaker 6: And then as a personal question,
would you be willing like, let's say,
would you compromise at all if, let's say,
Republicans in the GOP in the Senate particularly
wanted to enact something which you as a
progressive and just you personally be willing to
acquiesce or agree to, maybe including voter I.D.
being required as a part of that so long
as it doesn't disenfranchize people?
Or do you believe that voting ID is something
that should be non-negotiable from the Democrat
and the progressive side of things?
Speaker 1: So two part answer and these
are really, you know, you know, these are big
topics, right? So there's a lot of different
considerations. I am very skeptical of voter
ID because it is a transparently bad faith
way for Republicans to disenfranchize people. So
that's why I have such a problem with voter ID
as proposed and implemented. That
being said, if there was a voting
rights package that did significant
good things and codified them into law,
I'd be open to negotiating on voter ID, provided
I was satisfied that there really is, you know, it
can't cost money to get the documents, you need
to get the voter ID. It can't require rural poor
people to drive to the state capital in order to
get the documents they need to get the voter I.D.
like if I was really satisfied that all of those
things were were dealt with. I'd be willing to
negotiate on voter ID as part of a bigger voting
rights package. The problem is, in practice,
we know it's just a bad faith way to purge people
from voter rolls and prevent people from voting.
Speaker 6: Absolutely. Well, hey, I'm glad to have
talked with you, and I hope I lived up at least
moderately or mildly to the expectations.
And it's good to speak to you again and
please encourage all your voters like you
always do to register and go out and vote.
Speaker 1: Everyone must vote. Brody, thank you
so much for the call. Let's take a quick break,
but we're going right back to the phones in
a moment. So if you still want to talk to me
after hearing all of these calls, if you
still want to talk to me, just hang on.
All right, let's go back to the phones where
so many people want to chat. Let's start with
Jordan from Minnesota. Jordan, you're on the
air. Jordan, from Minnesota, you're on the air.
Not a great start. Not a great start
here, I guess. No, Jordan from Minnesota.